[Music]
just make some
all right so lucky number seven yes I
hope so absolutely a wild card is
fantastic but tell us a little bit about
the title of the album wild card where'd
that come from I got a tattoo last
October of a wild card up my sleeve the
Queen of Hearts and basically for a lot
of reasons but the main one being a
reminder that I'm the queen of my own
heart no matter what and I've pulled out
a few wild cards in my life so far just
random things whether it's relationships
or getting out of this bad for you or
going with your gut and doing something
that it's a risk being rewarding so I
felt like with this album and all that
it compasses it just felt like a great
title yeah I think it's safe to say that
it's a great title for the album that
song is awesome too but the album itself
it's like unapologetic it's feisty it's
country
now they don't let me like the key
[Music]
and it's it's true country and it is
brand labor it's got some rock and roll
on it for sure but it's no matter what I
say it's country yeah I love it and it's
you know I came out of a record the way
to these things it's really a little bit
more of a senior songwriter record it
was a double album too so it dove pretty
deep but this record I didn't overthink
it I just put something on it that I
loved and that I wanted to sing loved
and so far it's been great I mean but
it's just brand-new so we'll see what
happens it's gonna be so good and I
could like cannot stop listening to it
all comes out in the wash it's just like
so catchy then you love Bluebird and you
love free bitchin yeah Akeelah does cuz
it sounds like home to me she's got a
tennis player to it yeah absolutely
I'm so you wrote half of the album
before you took a break half of the
album after the break why was that break
so important to you I feel like I've
been doing this since I was 17 and I'll
be 36 on the 10th of November so I I
wasn't really sure how to take a break
because I haven't and I felt like you
kind of have to fall in love with it
again and you can't do that if you don't
miss it and I didn't choose the break my
manager suggested it strongly and she
was right cuz I just was a little tired
you know and um turns out I really
missed the road and that's a good
feeling I was like it took me about a
month see get used to not being on the
road I was writing it up really
supposing he's record in that time right
it's not like you weren't doing anything
yeah going on but I webinar you're
getting on the bus and that's training
it is but I missed it so much and so I'm
glad we're out on that um roadside bar's
peak guitar store right now in the next
January starts wildcard tour so having a
minute off gave me like also time to
live and write just do things on the
weekends cuz I'm always like hey I want
to go out it's Monday no we worked all
night yeah exactly
alright cool so that time of a break was
important for you personally and really
profession absolutely and just good to
take a minute for yourself absolutely
yeah no stuff
now you posted recently on Instagram
that before releasing an album that you
have this feeling of anxiety do you feel
that way now but it's released it's out
in the world I feel better when it's
like midnight on the day that it's out
it's just it is I mean it's for me I'm
really write about my life or people
really close to me laughs so it's kind
of like putting your diary out there for
everybody to read and sometimes it's a
little harder than others but this
record had so many fun moments on it
that it felt a little less stressful or
felt a little less anxious but it's
always always have the jitters and blues
sleep for a few knots before record
comes out I can't even imagine but it's
like you said it is deeply personal but
your lyrics are girl they are so clever
thank you oh good you're like oh my god
that's how I really feel whenever I'm in
that situations well that's another
thing is being brutally honest it's kind
of what I built my career on so I can I
have to stick to that but it's not
always easy but you know and then people
come up to me and say thanks you kind of
encapsulated how I was feeling in that
moment
[Music]
we're in New York City obviously so how
is that like played a part in the album
in your music in your life I love the
city I had only been here several times
but mostly to work in right kind of
Hotel Studios whatever I was doing and I
never really got to spend time
disappearing in the city and becoming
like part of it and it's got so much to
offer especially for a creative if
you're ready and open you know and so
how so how are you becoming part of the
Big Apple well I'm just well I'm trying
to learn how to get around my way yeah
I'm not and my husband's a local so he's
very it's a little impatient with me but
I forget there's like avenues and it's a
girl it evens and odds and the subway
not even a chance yet I've got a good
app so I can share with you because
we're both you know Nashville gals yes
but I'll share it with you and I'm
getting there yeah but yeah but this
town that much yet it's all good I
wanted to celebrate in life right now
obviously the new album Pistol Annies as
you mentioned you guys are on tour but
you're also a newly way I am no Brenda
and he is in your life yeah but I mean
how much joy does Brendan bring to your
life
it's really good to be genuinely happy I
mean you almost don't realize that
you're not until you get there and
you're like yeah and I didn't know that
there was a level of you know comfort
and happiness out there that existed
like that it's nice to to like come
through something hard and then know
that there's that on the other side of
it it's a really positive upbeat person
and so that's good for me because I tend
to lean negative if I can or Scorpio too
so I could but at your age we're good or
a good balance you know seduced me
excuse me and check well you deserve it
you deserve not being kept in check
well I deserve that honey you know you
know you gotta speak a little bit right
but no you deserve to find that
happiness and and that love what do you
love most about him though he's just
normal and cool like it's always smiling
like it's a really you know someone
that's that happy to be around there's
it there's no choice but to sort of like
it gets on everybody and
it's really great honey I gotta say like
on your insta post I think you have all
your fans smiling when they see the
househusband shirtless photos and vol 3
when she wins volume for coming out next
thing I'm promoting maybe it's already
I'm like it's funny cuz I posted I could
filter and it was like if you likes or
whatever and I posted him and it like
blew up oh honey
people love ya yeah look abs we'll get
to you know what kind of work on that my
favorite my personal favorite was
aligned with the weed eater
babe I mean that's a twofer right there
it is lookin man and he's you know
tending to the yard work you're like
dang girl laundry oh my gosh I love it
you think you'll include him in a music
video and each I should I mean he's like
a video baby but me like in there one of
those you would like like higher anyway
Yeah right what are they he's an
influencer right now anyway whatever I
love it let's see CMA Awards November 13
girlfriend you were nominated artist of
the Year nomination correct yes and
you're also gonna be performing so what
are you gonna be bringing to that CMA
stage probably some sequins oh yes
guitar clear the fort and I'm doing all
comes out in the wash my single so yeah
wait all comes out yeah it's fun and the
the saves that created for it's really
good really give us something
give us a Cutlass or end of the video
okay perfect in the video where girls
and fishnets and four-wheel drive so I
mean isn't that how we all roll around
Nashville or fishnets nerve truck
exactly
at 80 we love your passion and your work
with animals this is something that
you've done for years we chatted about
it and asked with mutt nation so why is
this a passion project of yours and why
do you get so much satisfaction with
working with animals I just grew up with
animals so when it came time for me to
pick a charity you know it was a
no-brainer for me but I didn't want to
necessarily get in with someone else's
attorney I wanted to kind of have
control because in my mind if I was
asking people to to donate money or to
volunteer their time I wanted to know
exactly where it was going so I started
my nation in 2009 and me and my mom and
we've raised over 4 million dollars and
say it is insane thousands of dogs and
our mission is to raise awareness for
shelter pets adopt don't shop in first
bay neuter in for people to know that
shelters aren't scary places you know
you might find your forever best friend
there if you just give it a chance and
people ask how to help besides donating
you know your time is so valuable to
these animals if you go and spend time
with these dogs or cats and take them
for walks and give them human
interaction it increases their chances
of adoptions that way so even if it's an
hour a week you know it really makes a
difference it's so cool that you're
doing that and you guys have done a
great great job with it and you've even
dug into your closet to help raise money
for him Yeah right I just cleaned out
I'm not good at all of that but I have
all these amazing things I've worn over
the years onstage and stuff and I didn't
know what to do with them really and so
we decided to put up an oxygen eBay with
socon to join in and help us do that to
you know take all this there's just some
great things that I have good memories
in yeah when you see that you're like
what do I do but now knowing that it's
going to the dogs it was so much easier
for me to like part with it it's going
to the dog
[Music]